welcome to this video playing eraser
double-oh-seven not a nice name seems
like he wants to erase people ok meth
from Turkey and we got got a [ __ ] on
with with an early the early two nights
the two nite variation of the calc on
how do I play that as usual i forgot my
own video I think he's six you don't
really get to this Bishop out of out of
the pond Shane if I remember correctly
then c5
interesting tries to tries to trip the
light that's not nice okay yeah f6 was
probably the only move but this doesn't
look too bad I mean night on f7 is not
badly placed if he decides to play
something exactly like that hmm yeah I
like this for black very much in fact
he's got quite quite strange piece set
up and I'm ready to play Bishop be 697
long castles just have the center here
so we should be six yeah probably let's
let's play quickly here this is some
probably this more than one way to to
obtain a decent position and spending
too much time is not not really helpful
if I have young I could take if I could
take h3e to speed up my development but
to this very much weakens the light
squares he is threatening a fire and
it's not just trapping the piece it's
right in her in a pin then this is the
real problem
okay again I spend time yes it's no use
even if I'm even when I am really
consciously try to avoid that I will
spend time and this is really one of
those cases where whites position is bed
anyway until you should just play
quickly okay still it's a ticking of
seven
yeah Queen takes I don't really have a
square for the rook I guess I need to
offer the exchange which you didn't take
yeah this was to be expected I'm really
hoping to have enough development here
against his King he still if he moves
this Bishop there's g2 hanging if you
move see wonders be to hanging and I'm
attacking the center maybe I could have
taken on d4 anyway but I thought this is
really good I mean this King is wide
open now
so rookie agent keen f king queen have
to mate and everyone is saying
yeah I guess that's it and white just
weakened position too much maybe you
should have taken the exchange or
something hard to say I mean black is
excellent here but here this
questionable should I really take I
don't like it from a positional point of
view would maybe I need to technically
yeah this is probably unnecessary I
should do that yet he must then prolly
exchange and then I'm so so well
developed it just avoids this business
hehe it's a question maybe you should
take one thing that I have thought as
possible this may be Bishop e3 tending
to take not sure if I would have doubt
that because it looks completely bonkers
computers has its equal and great
doesn't really help hey I maybe should
have grabbed this TM and I think it's
just too much development yeah the
computer is already giving a loss for
white you cannot cannot save this jae
and this is indeed term probably amid
even yeah I mean wrong button
this kind of player is really it's
probably too ambitious I mean at least
that one I mean maybe you can play it
for something but this is really nice
this is a good piece here and why it is
simply not developed enough to support
the center it's it's just good for like
I think alright thanks for watching